lately I'd say the anime has reached the
point where it can be considered a big
big industry just look at the number of
shows we get every season even the most
niche titles or the most generic ones
would undoubtedly find themselves being
some fans crowned treasure in the midst
of the pack season so it's only natural
that some standouts would inevitably
find themselves lost in the shuffle so
on this video we're gonna go through
some anime which I feel were quite
overlooked and didn't become popular
enough for what they deserved
specifically series which I haven't
talked about much on this channel let's
get started
it's no secret that I'm a fan of the
urban fantasy genre featuring superpower
teats you guys might be familiar with
this genre thanks to some nice anime
like the index fate and a bit more
recently boom go stray dogs and noragami
in the midst of all the great shows in
the spring 2015 season is blood blockade
Battlefront considering that this is the
season a soma Hachi man and Belle made
their debuts mr. koi wife through Wars
we're in full swing and ubw finished off
with a bang it's not too hard to get
lost in the shuffle not helping things
is that despite being a show with a
colorful cast blessed with interesting
abilities this series revolving around
Leonardo watch and his extraordinary
experiences in hell Salem's Lot ends up
being a mostly episodic mishmash of
adventures I still think the show's
quite nifty and definitely no slouch in
terms of style the episodic feel might
not be for everyone but I didn't feel
bored watching it and eagerly look
forward to the next episode when it was
airing in the end though I think that
despite some people's opinions of blood
blockade battlefront being a style over
substance show thanks to its episodic
nature it ultimately holds up and is a
fun way to get yourself lost in some
good old anime fun the characters are
fun and the art and the action are all
enjoyable enough for the show to be one
of the better popcorn series right
around the middle of the decade
next in line at number nine is golden
karmøy
before trailers or anything like that I
didn't really know what to expect out of
gold and Conway I certainly did get my
first major exposure to it thanks to the
memes and clips of the hilariously bad
CGI bear but that's not really a good
way to know what shows about now is it
so I decided to give it a shot and I
tell you what I don't regret it one bit
golden karmøy at first seemed more like
a gritty adventure series about survival
with the premise revolving around the
russo-japanese war and the subsequent
gold rush i figured that the show will
weave bits of history into an adventure
narrative starring a war veteran and his
partner i new girl turns out that i got
more than what I bargained for in a way
and came out of this rather unique
series with a more complete
understanding of Japan and the world
back then that's not to say that the
actions lacking but I certainly felt
that historical aspects of the show
could be considered the main focus is it
a bait-and-switch dwell decide for
yourself overall golden karmøy really
needs more love it's a nice notable
subversion of the historical fiction
genre where the action takes a back seat
to more documentary-like moments that
center around a new culture I know that
this kind of storytelling might not be
for everyone but I certainly think that
it's at least worth a shot
[Music]
so I games fans especially those keeping
their wallets thing and testing the
neverending gamble of the gotcha with
granblue fantasy and shadow verse might
recognize a lot of familiar faces here
you see sigh games has this habit of
somewhat remaking and reorienting
characters in their IP with their
various franchises which explains the
sense of deja vu brought about by their
first crack at an animated tie-in to one
of them mobile games before hitting big
internationally with GBF and Shadow
verse sigh game had this mobile game
called rage of behemoth and it's
animated tyne is probably one of the
more overlooked titles out there as far
as sigh game series are concerned I feel
that the series got overlooked at first
because it didn't seem to be anything
too special a medieval world of gods and
demons has always been a tried and
tested trend but the fact that it's a
tie-in to a game might have raised some
red flags to someone back in 2014 I mean
I love the whitcross anime and most card
game shows but let's face it most tie-in
series just don't break a lot of new
ground unless they're already tied to a
big franchise from the get-go
however the ever escalating stakes the
brilliant characters and the nice art
and world design completely surpassed my
expectations rage of Bahamut the genesis
might seem like your typical high
fantasy but it's one show that will
surely catch anyone's low expectations
off-guard and create an anime to
remember sai games and studio mapa
managed to take a card game world and
make an absolute winner out of it
coming out at the same time as Gurren
Lagann lucky star darker than black
Hayate the combat butler and a new
Nanoha isn't easy it's not hard to see
why Morabito guardian of the spirit
often gets overlooked or
underappreciated when looking at anime
in 2007 while anime fans were caught up
with grand adventure toward freedom or
chilling with kornata and friends
production i.g were doing a pretty neat
job at adapting some japanese fantasy
novels enter Morabito guardian of the
spirit the anime adaptation of the first
book in the Morabito series that tells
the story of the wandering warrior balsa
in the series balsa has been tasked with
protecting chagum together the two go on
a journey across a great land that has
obvious influences owning two indochina
sounds familiar well it should do in
spite of the seemingly standard premise
Morabito more than makes up for it in
terms of execution and character
development the arts are also an
extremely strong suit with palettes
resembling those you'd often see in
theatrical productions if you enjoy
stuff like sword of the stranger or
rurouni kenshin Morabito might be to
your liking it may have been overlooked
for over a decade but I think the Mori
beto is a prime example of gems that you
can find if you just dig hard enough
[Music]
you know the joke about how Atlas fans
only know about persona specifically the
game from three onwards the same thing
also applies to the type-moon fanbase
with most of them supposedly only
knowing fate/stay night and the billion
spin-offs prequels and games that
feature saber rin Gilgamesh and some of
stay night and granddaughter's iconic
characters to be fair I'm not surprised
that compared to the numerous fate
incarnations garden of sinners gets much
less love and popularity while the
action mystery in the series of movies
holds up is by no means an easy watch
compared to the straightforward
storytelling of fate and the Ilia shows
in the first place watching the movie
straight up would leave some viewers
confused because the story wasn't told
in chronological order that's to say
that the beauty of garden of sin is
strongly lies in its rewatch potential
the movie series is quite philosophical
and the cryptic dialogue that requires
multiple watches and some deep thinking
might take a while to get used to get
over those hurdles and you'll find
yourself in a unique experience that
revels in tackling mature issues
violence and a dark captivating mystery
that looks as good as it can get in
anime cinema now I think my garden of
sinners before Akatsuki Noyola as a
title that most casual Watchers have a
brief familiarity with you might have
heard of the name before or you might
have seen some pictures of it with its
signature art style and character
designs Akatsuki no Yan are known as
Yona of the dawn can be described as
princessy on his coming-of-age story
born as the sole heir to the throne his
sheltered life of luxury quickly takes a
downturn at the murder of her father
barely escaping with her childhood
friend Yanis life turns upside down as
she sees firsthand the real state of the
kingdom her request to reclaim the
throne won't be easy but it will
certainly be a dramatic and grand
iOpener in a vacuum I don't think the
series is really overlooked or
underappreciated it does have a fan base
and was quite a nice [ __ ] back in 2014
but you've got to remember that 2014 was
also the year of your lie in April
parasite Tokyo ghoul Missa koi and no
game no life however I certainly didn't
see a lot of people talking about Yona
relative to what I actually think it
deserves visually stunning with an
extremely engaging plot Akatsuki no Yona
in my opinion is one of the benchmark
action shoujo shows of that decade that
everyone deserves to at least sit
and take a look at this is a real
curious case in my opinion Battleship
Yamato 2199 is one of the most enduring
series with a legacy to speak of to give
you a bit of context it's a series that
revolutionize the space opera genre in
anime and some people have called it the
mediums equivalent of Star Trek that's
why when the remakes started coming in a
couple of years back I wasn't surprised
when it was one of the key recipients of
the remake treatment nonetheless at this
time it's it's in the thousands in Mal
popularity and not a lot of people
really talked about it back in 2012 I
guess it was the medium of distribution
to blame back then after all instead of
giving us the remake in a full series
you have quite an erratic schedule that
caused it to start in 2012 and finish in
late 2013 and that is a shame really
because I think mostly that the remake
of Battleship Yamato 2199 is one of the
better ones out there the transition of
the series from the 70s to the modern
era was done seamlessly and masterfully
it's a remake that does justice to the
legendary anime that helped bring about
the rise of the sci-fi genre in its time
and if you're itching to watch a remake
of some oldies make sure you don't give
this title a pass at the shutter
the Prohibition era is probably one of
the most popular areas in American
history set in an era of lawlessness 91
days is a story revolving around Angela
goose' and its quest for revenge against
the vanetti family sounds like one of
those classic literature titles you've
probably come across while in school
right in terms of aesthetics I'd say
that it reminded me of buck I know the
story ends up being a slow burn with
tension slowly increasing and erupting
in a big culmination in the climax
revenge and crime drama stories aren't a
dime a dozen in the anime world so what
sort of anticipated the show's fate when
it comes to connecting with the typical
viewer nevertheless I don't regret
picking this show up one bit as at its
peak it's a gripping dramatic story that
encapsulates what you'd expect out of a
dark thriller featuring this sort of
setting I barely heard anyone talking
about the series when it was airing and
I definitely don't think I heard anyone
talking about it after it finished
either and that is a shame in my opinion
because I think that this series
deserves to get a lot more
[Music]
20:18 was a year of hard hitters and
among the series introduced during that
year Pina Matsui is by far one of the
funniest ones out there
the story of neeta's misadventures with
Hina got quite a bit of traction when it
aired a couple of years back but I think
the popularity it got was a bit less
than what it actually deserved given how
funny the show is and how witty it is as
a comedy
I think the Hina Matsuri is a show that
would be great to recommend to anyone
who craved some quick laughs the shows
extremely strong in terms of writing its
characters and their quirks the jokes
come out of left field and would leave
anyone in stitches for hours on end
comedy character reactions directions
and timing all come together to make
this one of the best comedies of the
year I think that the show deserves more
love than it got from the general
community and actually now that I think
about it it was probably one of my
favorite non-sequel animes of 2018 if
you love comedy anime please do yourself
a favor and watch it it will be the best
decision of your life Audino nakka nakka
nakka mono Sakura so there's an
antibiotic ronita genie no doko
detonator
cut it I said they don't allow you to
contact them now where do we start with
rainbow not a lot of shows deal with the
dark side of justice in the system of
the world and among them I think that
rainbow is one of the most cynical and
downright realistic ones in terms of
showing how messed up the world can be
the gritty tale of survival featuring
prison inmates has carved out a
reasonable niche for itself back then
but then not a lot of people still
remember it compared to its
contemporaries given the subject matter
and the sheer graphic nature it's not
surprising that the show would be under
appreciated compared to a lot of stuff
that deals with similar topics in its
time with that being said though I
really vouch for this series because
it's not afraid to go down and dirty in
his depictions of social injustice and
the nature of criminal justice rainbow
is a grim and dark tale of survival
that's one of the most serious stories
that I've ever ever seen in anime
prepare your tissues for rainbow is a
series that will take you on a wild ride
in a world wind of emotions it's a truly
depressing series that show some grim
dark realities and I think that it
deserves more love for the sheer
boldness it took especially considering
the medium of anime as a whole 10 titles
10 underappreciated gems have you
already seen some of these if so I would
love to know about your time with them
and what you saw in them I'll be going
over the comments myself and I'd love to
talk more about these shows with you
would you like to see a volume 2 for
this one
well if this video gets 10,000 likes
I'll definitely consider making one to
make sure you subscribed and hit that
notification bail button so you never
miss any of my uploads I'll see you next
time on vinnie tube
[Music]